[Music]
no more gray skies for adele fans
[Music]
we have the new music video for her
latest single easy on me the grammy
winner's first new song in five years so
i'm very very humbled i had no time to
choose
what i chose to do
the track is the lead single from
adele's highly anticipated next album
30. now let's look a little closer at
the video
more than 135 000 fans were standing by
on adele's youtube page on thursday for
the premiere
and by the end of the video's debut
nearly 300 000 people were tuned in
[Music]
and if this house looks familiar that's
because it's the same house from adele's
chart topping ballad hello
and if the aesthetic seems similar
director xavier dolan helms both of
these videos
[Music]
overall there's plenty of imagery about
moving on or maybe goodbye reflecting on
love and leaving the past behind as
adele heads toward her next chapter
there ain't no gold
in this river
this big debut follows adele's candid
interview with british vogue last month
where she revealed what she hopes her
son nine-year-old angelo will take away
from the album
she told the mag that angelo had a lot
of questions following her divorce from
his father what's my next album to be
based on
divorce babe divorce so yeah we may have
a good idea of who adele might be
talking to in the new single
[Music]
adele explained quote i just felt like i
wanted to explain to him through this
record when he's in his 20s or 30s who i
am and why i voluntarily chose to
dismantle his entire life in the pursuit
of my own happiness it made him really
unhappy sometimes
and that's a real wound for me that i
don't know if i'll ever be able to heal
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you